you ready let's do it
it'll look cute the ultimate forged in
fire matchup you are the forest and fire
Champion two Champion blades in a deadly
weapon Showdown it will kill two blades
One champion
decide the winner forged in fire war of
weapons
the Epi to combat gentlemen this blade
can be seen wielded by Arya Stark from
Game of Thrones
my name is Trevor Kroll I've been making
knives since
I was probably 10 or 11 years old knife
making for me is a vacation every time
I'm on that Forge that's what I do for
fun
if I win the ten thousand dollars oh my
wife's already cabbage done with that
money I will never see a dime of that
the famous sword needle wielded by Arya
Stark in the Game of Thrones series
draws its inspiration from the Epi to
combat an unassuming but vicious sword
designed primarily for thrusting the
Blade's lightweight and needle point
allows for deadly thrusts as Arya
inflicted vengeance upon her enemies the
Epi to combat also featured a guard to
protect the user's hand a necessary
feature for the weapon Arya used in her
quest to avenge the Stark family
the Bastard Sword my name is Phil but
they call me Sergeant cheese Badger I'm
from Wisconsin I'm a former Marine and
I'm here to take home the victory I'm
not dropping a flying elbow off the top
ropes but I'm just gonna try to make the
sickest blade I can the Bastard Sword
was widely popular throughout Europe
during the Middle Ages and well into the
Renaissance
it's so well known a version of this
deadly blade was wielded by the famous
bastard Jon Snow in HBO's Game of
Thrones
while its blade length varied from 36 to
40 inches the name came from its
uniquely sized handle that was between
one and two hands long earning its
alternative name the hand and a half
sword lethal in battle the sword could
easily deliver devastating blows with
two hands or quickly inflict slashes in
close quarter combat with one
I'm about to start making the fa to
combat
I've chosen 5160 it's good tough Spring
Steel
I hit the length I was aiming for to a
point where I think it's in good shape
I've never ground Fullers before it's a
huge learning curve for me so it's going
to be critical
I get the Fuller cut into the back I'm
trying to grind on the front side and
they're not working
it's not cutting to the depth that I
wanted it's grinding it flat it's
frustrating the hell out of me
yeah
I've messed up my Center Line badly I've
got like six center lines now
I wanted to have both sides of the
Fullers completed today and I still got
to get this blade quenched so I hope
that I can finish this blade
I work my Fullers down to a point where
I'm satisfied and I decided to it's time
to clean
she took I think that's pretty good the
updated combat is supposed to be light
and fast and my blade turned out to be
really thin and pretty light I think
it'll be a good blade
[Music]
so my plan with this build is to make
the blade out of Damascus it's probably
enough it's probably too much the reason
why I want to make Damascus is I want my
blade to be over the top and I think
it's going to look awesome and the
Billet is solid so I'm feeling pretty
confident about it all right I got the
profile right where I want and I'm
getting ready to quench my blade
Anything could happen when you go into a
quench it could crack or bend or warp
and I really don't want that to happen
it's time to go in for the quench
I don't hear any pings I don't hear any
Tings all right everything looks great
we might have a good sword I have enough
here to grind a straight blade which is
awesome
mild steel is so soft it almost just
drills like wood look at that so I'm
going through my tap and die set and I'm
realizing that the smallest set that I
have is a quarter inch and my Tang is
nowhere near that wide like a weld that
Palm a lot if I have five more hours I
would definitely thread that Tang it's
just a tighter construction but I need
to move on so I'm going with the
painting because I'm running out of time
hopefully it all stays tight
all right blade splits this is the kill
test
that will take your weapon and deliver
some thrust and slashes on our Dummy
from the north
Trevor you're up first you ready for
this I'm ready let's do it
all right Trevor first up it is so light
just like a needle your point here
allows for a very deep penetration
without any effort overall certain it
will kill
good job all right Phillip you're up you
ready ready
oh my gosh very cool very cool so right
off I like the scale of your blade I
mean it's very large but and it's got a
lot of weight to it but the balance is
nice you can see all these cuts are so
deep I was actually worried on that last
one that I would hit the post that's
holding that thing up but uh as far as
being a cutting sword this thing is
lethal good job thank you all right
gentlemen it's time for the strength
test
to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades just like an
ice pick I'm going to be chipping iced
Trevor you up first you ready I'm ready
[Music]
okay Trevor you did pick up a slight
Bend in your tip
having said that I mean this thing is so
light which is fantastic thank you
bladesmiths Welcome to our strength test
the WWE Dash Fest
The Edge holding ability and overall
construction I'm going to go through a
series of WWE weapons we're going to
destroy the table puncture and Bash
through the garbage can and just tear
that ladder to pieces
foreign
[Music]
two blades One champion you decide the
winner forged in fire war of weapons